uh you're obviously a Cowboys fan right
no no okay this is interesting who's
your team
I want to say I was to take some Spanish
whoa Texas
Jesus Christ you're getting Robin
tongues with DeSean Watson or what
what's going on and that's that's the
whole reason when I was today being
cloudy first
[__] beast
you meant to say Bust but he was a beast
in college he was and then and then
obviously JJ Watt everyone thought you
had JJ white cloudy it's over but it
wasn't over we had uh clown I mean we
had the badger we had the defense was
stacked at one point in time yeah honey
badger was on the team oh so you're a
[__] you're from Dallas and you're a
Texans fan
what is going on there I don't think I
like football no more though I don't
think how does that happen it was the
players like I was a I used to be a
Cowboys fan like I used to watch my dad
throw the controller at the TV a lot of
that ain't left the game did you decide
I don't want to live this stressful life
I did I watched my dad if I damned to
fight his knees one game and I said oh
no oh yeah I can never be like that and
so I ended up falling in love with JJ
watch David and clowning people like
that man it just kind of Drew me to
restart off with JJ though and that kind
of Drew me to the team and then
I just was a Texas Fan after that did
your dad look at you like yeah how could
you asked me for it I was gonna say I
can imagine
well I'm a Suns fan and one of my
younger Sons is pretty much growing up
in La so he's a Laker fan and I hate him
for it
like if he was here he'd probably say he
ain't no damn Texas but then but when
the suns are in the finals he wants to
put on a [__] son's Jersey that's
crazy it's a little nine-year-old ass
yeah I'm pretty sure if the Texans ever
go to the Super Bowl he don't want to be
there
but as and if the Dallas Cowboys ever go
to the Super Bowl
they don't do that don't do that I
almost said without laughing but come on
guys don't do that Mike McCarthy's your
coach anyway oh man I'm sure you'll
support uh yeah I got two man I got two
not two you guys got the crazy I went to
WrestleMania
at your stadium in Plano it's not Plano
I stayed in Plano Madison uh the stadium
is in Arlington no I stayed in Plano by
the way shout out to Plano some chicks
over there in Plano too yeah there's a
uh what's the name of that restaurant
where they dress like a lumberjack
prostitutes
uh uh boomerjacks no no no no no it's
like Hooters but like like [__]
checkered you got boomerjacks you got
Twin Peaks Twin Peaks yeah
to a twin peaks in Plano ahead of time
you gotta go to uh the Twin Peaks what's
the one that we'd be going to before we
go to the club
Bombshells bombshell go to bombs yeah
okay yeah yeah nice shout out to Plano
no but I went to the [__] stadium for
Wrestlemania that [__] was crazy so a
lot of people don't even know that's why
I damn near kind of got to be a Cowboys
fan again because I just like the
technique just did a Remix They want me
to do a remix for Texas for for the
stadium next year just for the stadium
for the Cowboys well it's that I mean
for the Cowboys for the stadium oh
you're a Cowboys fan
which one of those overpaid bumps
jerseys are you gonna wear with the
video
I wonder can I just give my name
hey you know what though Trayvon
I said overpaid
I'm really only speaking about well ZK
Elliott ain't even on the team anymore
Dak Prescott like come on like you know
you know who's a beast wear the digs
Jersey Diggs
[Applause]
yeah yeah
yeah not a fan of him huh
do you guys have some interactions or
something
I mean I am an interactions with nobody
out of all of the Cowboys players since
you've been able old enough to go to
clubs who's the most outside
okay
who's outside so I like I go to clubs
but I'll go to like I still go to hole
in the walls like I love that's my [__]
I go to who showed me love from the jump
yeah and so for the first time ever I
went to like a
I go in there
and every Cowboys players and
decking there with his shirt on button
he [__] up uh it was just everybody
was in there everybody was in there so I
can't even just say one of them because
they was you should have brought your
dad with you so he could have went over
to Dak and said get the [__] home and
study so we could win a [__] playoff
game you soft ass [__] what are
we doing I look at him I said that's why
y'all now
I'm a Suns fan and I have good friends
on the sons
and a couple of them just they're at my
club a lot right so they're big
customers for our club you know 11 11 in
Scottsdale and uh
during the season you know I gotta be
like hey do I say something you gotta
leave at eight hey man are you sure you
wanna
buy 10 bottles tonight there's a game
tomorrow
yeah yeah
and they pay it too every time because
they yeah I've never been to a club
where you you literally get ones just to
throw them just it's like a net hanging
party just to stupid so you admit saying
I I endorse I'm not gonna lie it's a
bunch of Cowboy players and I gotta I
gotta try to do something but I ended up
gaining some friends Jaylen someone
named Jalen rigger oh yeah our weaker
yeah he's the white out yeah he was on
the eagle he was on the Eagles yeah he
played for the Minnesota now yeah
yeah yeah he was there a lot of people
there what about have you ever hung with
DeSean Watson no I have not I probably
won't probably matter I feel like he'd
be a good time
just go hit an Asian massage parlor with
them
at the club when he said hey man I got
this stuff Have you ever been to a rub
and tug
it's like a massage parlor right where
you go to and there's like a little old
Asian lady in show like rub you down uh
I want to one time and then she'll flip
you over and then she'll jerk you off I
want to but I don't want to know that
that's what it is you kind of gotta know
that's what it is though otherwise it's
awkward no it's not gonna be awkward
I feel like it's not going to be ugly if
you go to one and you don't know it's
like kind of just like a oh it says like
what is this what is this why are you
reaching around and then you just go you
just go with the flow I don't think it's
just yeah I feel like you knowing that
you're going now now you got to sneak in
and no I just I'm gonna go get a massage